>>> IT IS COFFEE TIME.
AS YOU PREPARE YOUR MORNING CUP
OF COFFEE OR TEA THERE IS A
SERIOUS NEW HEALTH CONCERN
ABOUT A POPULAR 0-CALORIE
SWEETENERS.
ACCORDING TO A NEW STUDY IT IS
LINKED TO AN INCREASED RISK OF
HEART ATTACK, STROKE AND EVEN
DEATH AND A RANGE OF FOODS,
ESPECIALLY QUITO DIET PRODUCTS
BUT IT IS HARD TO IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC DRINKS FOR FOODS THAT
CONTAIN.
ACCORDING TO THE SUNNY THERE IS
NO RULE REQUIRING THE SWEETENER
TO BE NAMED ON A PRODUCT LABEL.
WHY AS THAT.
LET'S DISCUSS AT CORNELL.
THAT'S WHERE I GO TO MEDICINE.
DR. DREW IS ALSO A CONTRIBUTOR
TO THE NEW YORKER.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
GOOD MORNING WHAT ARE THE
HEALTH CONCERNS AND WHY ISN'T
THIS LISTED?
>> AN ARTIFICIAL SWEETENER THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE USE AND IT HAS
GAINED POPULARITY IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
IT LOOKS LIKE SUGAR AND TASTES
LIKE SUGAR BUT DOESN'T HAVE THE
CALORIES AND IT DOESN'T AFFECT
OUR BLOOD LEUKOSIS LEVEL.
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES TEND TO
USE IT.
PEOPLE WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF
ERYTHRITOL IN THEIR BLOOD HAD
MUCH HIGHER RISKS OF CARDIAC
PROBLEMS.
THEY THINK THE MECHANISM MIGHT
BE IT ACTIVATES PLATELETS AND
CAUSES OUR BLOOD TO CLOT AND
CAUSING ALL KINDS OF DOWNSTREAM
PROBLEMS.
>> AND ASK REAL QUICKLY.
EXCUSE ME.
I USE A SWEETENER IN MY COFFEE.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT THAN
THOSE SWEETENERS OR IS IT
DIFFERENT.
I'M SURE PEOPLE USE THOSE
DIFFERENT SWEETENERS AS WELL.
>> ERYTHRITOL IS MIXED IN WITH
SPLENDA, TRIVIA.
THESE SWEETENERS CONTAIN THIS
BECAUSE IT HELPED SPOKE UP AND
ADD TO THE SWEETENER AND GIVE
IT THAT SUGARY FEELING.
>> GOT IT.
>> DIDN'T THE FDA PROVE THIS?
>> THE FDA APPROVED THIS IN
2001.
THIS IS NEW RESEARCH AND
PRELIMINARY RESEARCH.
ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST PASS AND
THERE IS A LOT OF LIMITATIONS
AS WELL.
THEY FOUND PEOPLE WITH HIGHER
LEVELS IN THEIR BLOOD TEND TO
HAVE HIGHER RISK.
CORRELATION AND NOT CAUSATION
AND FOCUSED ON PEOPLE WITH
DIABETES, PEOPLE WITH HEART
DISEASE AND IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
THIS HAS THE SAME EFFECTS FOR
THE GENERAL POPULATION.
>> I WANT TO SWITCH SUBJECTS
FOR A MOMENT.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN THIS
COMPANY AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
YOU HAVE A NEW PIECE WHERE YOU
TALK ABOUT THIS IDEA THAT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE COULD
BE USED TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
CAN ARTIFICIAL MINDS HEAL REAL
ONES.
WHAT CAN WE GAIN OR LOSE AND
LETTING THEM TRY.
THERE ARE HUGE RISKS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT CAN WRONG AND
YOU THINK THERE CAN BE SOME
UPSIDE HERE.
>> WE KNOW AMERICA IS GOING
THROUGH AN ENORMOUS MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
ONE IN FIVE HAS SOME KIND OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM AND A LOT
OF THAT IS DUE TO OUR USE OF
TECHNOLOGY AND WE HAVE THESE
MORE POWERFUL TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
AI CHAD FOX.
YOU THINK IT'S A BAD THING BUT
THERE ARE REAL RISKS AND REAL
POTENTIAL.
THESE THINGS CAN HELP US SCALE
TREATMENT AND BEFORE EVERYONE
NEEDED A ONE-ON-ONE THERAPIST
AND THIS IS THE WAY WE CAN
AUTOMATE THAT.
THESE AI RHYTHMS CAN LOOK
THROUGH OUR MEDICAL RECORDS AND
SOCIAL MEDIA USE AND SLEEP
HABITS.
PUT ALL THESE THINGS TOGETHER
AND GIVE US A VIEW OF OUR